okay we've learned about methods for
regression and for classification and
building predictors and for predicting
making predictions from our data
how do we test these out well ideally
we'd like to get a new sample from the
population and see how well our
predictions do
well we don't always have new data so
what do we do
and we can't use our training data just
straight off because it's going to be a
little bit optimistic
so
we're going to tell you about
cross-validation
is going to tell you about cross
validation which is a very clever device
for using the same training data to tell
you how well your prediction method
works
the other thing
i'm going to give my entire lecture i'll
try not to rob just in case you miss out
some of the salient points
the other thing we're going to look at
is standard errors of estimators
sometimes our estimators are quite
complex and we'd like to know the
standard error which means what happens
we've got new samples from the
population over and over again and we
recomputed our estimate and the standard
area is the standard deviation of those
estimates under resampling
well of course we can't re-sample from
the population we only have one sample
again rob's going to tell you about the
bootstrap which is a very clever device
for using the one single training sample
you have to estimate things like
standard deviations
rob okay well for that thanks for that
great introduction uh good overview so
we're going to talk about
cross-validation in the bootstrap as
trevor mentioned and these are
resampling methods so the word
resampling that our original data is a
sample we're going to resample use our
we actually sample from our data set in
order to learn about the
quantity of interest and the cross
validation the bootstrap are both ways
of resampling from the data
and the purpose of it is to get
information about the additional
information about the fitted model for
example
the main thing we use cross validation
for is to get an idea of the
the test set error of our model right we
have we're going to review that concept
of training error and we'll see as we've
talked about before the training error
is is too optimistic the more we fit the
data the lower the training error but
the test error can get higher if we
overfit it often will
so cross-validation is a very important
tool that we're going to we're going to
talk about in this section and we'll use
throughout the course to get a good idea
of the test set error of our
of a model
bootstrap on the other hand is most
useful to get idea of the variability or
standard deviation of an estimate and
it's bias
so we'll talk about first cross
validation and then bootstrap
so but let's before we get into those
let's review the idea of the concept of
training air versus test error
remember test error is the area that we
incur on new data so we fit our model to
a training set we take our model and
then we apply it to new data that the
model hasn't seen
the test error is actually how well
we'll do on future data the model hasn't
seen
training error
is much easier to compute we can do it
on the same data set what is it it's the
error we get
applying the model to the same data from
which we we trained
right and as you can imagine training
area is often quite
it's lower than test error the model has
already seen that the training set so
it's going to fit the training set
with lower error than it is going to
occur on a test set
and the more we overfit the harder we
fit the data the lower the training
error looks
on the other hand the test error can be
quite a bit higher so training air is
not a good surrogate for test air
and this picture is a good good one to
look at to summarize the the concepts
here so what do we have here well first
of all
along the horizontal axis is the
the model complexity low from low to
high for example in our
a linear model the model complexity is
the uh
the number of features the number of
coefficients that we fit in the model so
low means a few number of features or
coefficients or predictors high means a
large number
think about fitting a polynomial with
higher and higher degree right you can
see our model complexity increases with
degree so we move to the right we'd have
a higher complexity higher order of
polynomial the prediction error is on
the vertical axis and we have two curves
here
the training error in blue
and the test error in red
so what do we see let's first look at
the blue curve on the on the left
the model complexity is low for example
we're fitting a small number of
parameters maybe just a single a single
constant
the training error is high now as we
increase the model complexity we fit
more and more
features in the model or higher
complexity or higher order polynomial
the training error goes down
and actually this picture it continues
to go down a consistent way in most
cases for most models the more complex
the model the training error will go
down
as it does in this case
on the other hand the test error is the
red curve it does not consistently go
down
starts off high like the training air
comes down for a while but then it
starts to come up again it has a minimum
looks like around the middle here but
after this point
the more complex the model the higher
the tester
what's happened there well that is
is example of overfitting right
on on the left we've
we've added complexities and features
that actually are important for
predicting the response so they reduced
the test error but at that point we seem
to have fit
all the important features and now we're
putting in things which are which are
just noise
the the training error goes down as it
has to but the test error is starting to
go up that's overfitting right so we
don't want to overfit because we'll
increase the test error
the training error has not told us
anything about overfitting because it's
using the same data to
to to measure error the more the more
the more parameters the better it looks
so it's not a good um
it does not give us a good idea of the
test error the test error curve on the
other hand is minimized around this
level at this mile complexity and beyond
that is overfitting
um the ingredients prediction error are
actually
are bias and variance
so the bias is how far off on the
average the model is from the truth
the variance is how much that that
the estimate varies around its average
when we don't have we don't fit very
hard the bias is high
the variance is low because there's a
few parameters being fit
as we increase the model complexity
moving to the right
the bias goes down because the model can
adapt to more and more
subtleties in the data but the variance
goes up because we have we have more and
more parameters to estimate from the
same amount of data
so bias and variance together give us
prediction error and there's a trade-off
they sum together to give prediction
here and the trade-off
is minimized in this case around a model
complex near the middle here
so bias and variance together together
give us test error
we want to find the the model complexity
giving the smallest test error
and training error does not give us a
good idea of that
of test here and they refer to it as the
bias variance tradeoff
okay so
we can't use training error to estimate
test error as the previous uh picture
shows us so what do we do well
uh the best solution if we have a large
test set we can use that we simply take
our model that we've applied to the
fit on the training set apply it to the
test set
but
uh very often we don't have a large test
yet so if we can't do that what do we do
well there are there are some ways to
um
get an idea of test error using an
adjustment to training here basically
training error can be too small as we've
seen in the previous picture so these
methods
adjust the training error
by um
increasing it
by a factor that involves the amount of
fitting that we've done to the data and
the variance
and these methods include this the cp
statistic
the eic and the bic
okay we'll talk about these later on in
the course not in this section
here instead we're going to talk about
cross validation or validation and cross
validation and these involve removing
part of the data holding it out
fitting the date fitting the model to
the remaining part
and then applying that uh
the fitted model to the the the data
that we've held out and this is this is
called validation or cross validation as
we'll see
so let's first of all talk about the
validation approach so here we're going
to
the simple idea is basically we're going
to divide the data into two parts at
random
approximately of equal size
we'll call the first part of training
set and the second part the validation
or holdout set so the idea is simple we
take the model we fit it out on the
training half
and then we apply the the fitted model
to the other half the validation or
holdout set
and we record the error that we get on
the holdout set
and that error the validation set error
provides us a good idea of the of the
test error well at least some
idea of the test error
and the error will measure by mean
square error in the case of quantitative
response
or
misclassification error or rate in the
case of a qualitative or discrete
response classification
okay so just to make that clear let's
look at the next slide we have our data
set here i've divided it in two at
random
the blue part in the left is the
training set and the
orange part or pink part on the right is
the validation or holdout set these
observations for example 7 22 and 13 and
more of them are part
at random chosen to be in the training
set
observation 91 was at random chosen to
be in the holdout set
we fit the model to the blue part and
then we apply it and predict the
observations in the pink part
okay and that's we that's validation or
we might call that twofold validation
where we
well i shouldn't call it twofold because
as we'll see we don't cross over this is
simply a one stage process we divide it
in half
train on one half and predict on the
other half
that seems a little
wasteful if you've got a very small data
set right yeah that is wasteful and
as we'll see it's cross-validation will
uh remove that waste and be more
efficient but let's first of all see how
this works
um
in the uh
the auto data we're trying to recall
we're comparing the
linear model to higher order polynomials
in regression
and we had 392 observations divided up
into so we divide up into two parts at
random
196 in one part and
1096 the other part
first part being the training set and
the other part being the validation set
um
here's
if we do this once
we do a single split and we record the
mean square error
we get this red curve as a function of
the degree of the polynomial so a linear
fits on the left and quadratic is here
etcetera as we increase the polynomial
order
and we see the minimum seems to occur
maybe around two
well it's it's rising a bit and coming
down a bit after that it's pretty flat
after about two so it looks like a
linear model actually a quadratic model
excuse me is probably the best and then
after that we're not getting much gain
if any at all
but look what happens when we repeat
this process with more and more splits
at random into two parts we have a lot
of variability right
um
the minimums does
tend to occur around two
generally but look at the error it's
it's a varying from about 16 up to 24
depending on the split
so this is this is a consequence part of
the fact that we divided the data up
into two parts and there's
when you divide data in two you get a
lot of variability depending on the
split the training set for example is
half as big as it was originally
so it's interesting rob that even though
you get that variability it seems to
often have this pattern where the shape
of the curves are much the same right
but the the height the level
just hops around
so that's a good point and it actually
reminds me to say there's two things you
want to use uh validation for or cross
validation both to pick the the best
size of the model in this case the
degree of polynomial and also to give us
an idea of how good the error is to get
an idea of the actual test error at the
end of the
of the fitting process so
a twofold this this uh
breaking up into two parts is successful
at the first thing as trevor just
mentioned the minimum is around two
pretty consistently
so that seems to be okay but the actual
level of the curve is varying a lot so
wouldn't be so good at telling us an
idea of the error because we get a very
wide range here
in air
so
so i've said a little bit of this first
point already that um
it's this method is highly variable
because we're splitting into two parts
and
um there's lots of ways to split data
into two parts and because we're
splitting in two we're losing a lot of
the
um
the power in the training set we're
throwing away half the data each time in
the in training
and
another consequence because of that is
that you remember our original one of
our original questions was well
what's the what's the best size model to
pick second of all how well does that
model do in terms of test error
our training sets here are half as big
as our original training set let me go
back to this previous slide um right
we've split the data in half
we actually want the test error for for
a training set of size n we're getting
idea of test error for a training set of
size n n over two
and that's likely to be quite a bit
higher
than
the
uh the error for
a training set of size n and
why wrong why
that was my question okay
well that's because in in general the
more data one has the lower the error
right if i if i offer you a choice of
would you rather have 100 observations
or 200 observations you generally like
200 observations to train on because the
more data the more information you have
and in general the lower your error is
so if your training sets only half as
big as your original training set
as it is in this situation the error
that it it yields is probably going to
be higher than the actual air you want
to get
so as we can see there are some some
drawbacks of validation
in the next section we'll talk about
cross-validation which will help to
remove some of these drawbacks